my name is Conan O'Brien and no I'm not
a white Walker so sick of that keep
walking yeah go and people are like look
the I yeah trying trying to stab you
with shards of glass no crazy here as
always comic-con is incredibly crowded
isn't it amazing it is so crowded here's
how crowded comic-con is I had to wait
in line for three hours just to host
this show cuz I'm just waiting
you
man it is really great it's very great
to be at comic-con surrounded by so many
powerful superheroes
it is especially especially on the day
that OJ Simpson was paroled I have to
tell you
[Applause]
safety hey are they booing me Oh Jay I
don't know what they're booing they're
saying they're saying Jews I'm just
saying juju so good
the Jews yeah that's nice that's nice
anything to make that guy feel better
good job a big announcement yesterday
from the creators of Game of Thrones you
probably heard this that people behind
Game of Thrones are creating a new show
about the South winning the Civil War
yeah yeah yeah true story yeah it's
called the trump administration
speaking of Game of Thrones speaking of
Game of Thrones during the premiere of
Game of Thrones this is true who's in
all the papers all the sites during the
premiere of Game of Thrones fewer people
were watching online porn that's true
yeah yeah apparently for that one hour
the only thing coming was winter
No why did you do that again why did you
do it again and then to give me that
afterward he's like we did it kid it's
your nipple and my rubber we're going
places
[Laughter]
you